britain's queen elizabeth will not
attend the upcoming u.n climate
conference in nearby scotland she is
instead following her doctor's advice to
rest last week you'll recall the 95 year
old was hospitalized for a night
roxanna seberry is in windsor now where
the queen we understand is still doing
some work roxanna good morning
good morning tony the queen was expected
to meet president biden and other global
leaders in glasgow on monday but
buckingham palace says she's been
advised to stay here at the castle and
rest performing only light duties in a
statement the palace says she's
disappointed not to attend the u.n
summit in scotland she'll deliver a
recorded video message instead the news
comes a day after queen elizabeth held
virtual meetings from here at windsor
castle with the ambassadors of
switzerland and south korea they were
her first official engagements since she
stayed overnight in a london hospital
last week the palace said she underwent
what it described only as preliminary
investigations and that she was
following her doctor's advice to rest
before that she'd been carrying out
official engagements almost daily just
last tuesday the 95 year old monarch
hosted bill gates and other billionaire
business leaders here in windsor but the
cancellation of her trip to the climate
conference is sure to raise concerns
sunday times royal correspondent roya
nica told us she thinks there will be a
gear change in the kind of work the
queen does and the distances she travels
nika also expects the queen's workload
to now be under constant review jerica
all right roxanna seberry force in
windsor thank you